hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt ich
zeige euch heute die wohnung meiner
eltern die wir gerade gebaut haben und
die sie jetzt bald beziehen werden und
ich zeige euch wie man moderne und
altersgerechter features einbauen
[Musik]
ich habe ja relativ früh geheiratet mit
19 schon und wir sind damals auch
wirklich direkt mit murat in die nähe
meiner eltern gezogen es war ganz
kurzfristig und spontan da hatte nämlich
der mieter von mein papa gekündigt und
es war einfach die wohnung direkt im
nachbarhaus und wir haben gesagt warum
eigentlich nett wir ziehen einfach ins
nachbarhaus und sind dann im rat
eingezogen und später sind wir sogar
wieder ins haus meiner eltern
zurückgezogen einfach irgendwie andere
wohnung und wir haben echt immer mit ihm
zusammen gelebt bis zu dem zeitpunkt als
wir den ort gewechselt haben also von
waghäusel wiesental nach waghäusel
kirrlach und da hatten wir praktisch
fünf kilometer abstand zu meinen eltern
und irgendwie habe ich sie in der zeit
schon ziemlich vermisst wir haben zwar
jeden tag gesehen aber es gab auch echt
wochen wo ich sie einfach mal eine woche
nicht gesehen habe und das ist halt echt
zu viel und ich wusste irgendwann wenn
wir bauen damit meinen eltern zusammen
und dann bekommen sie eine wohnung bei
uns also wichtig war mir wir haben
unsere wohnung sie haben ihre wohnung
jeder hat so seine privatsphäre
aber wir sind trotzdem alle unter einem
dach und gerade mit kindern ist es echt
perfekt wind ii mit oma und opa zusammen
aufwachsen können
deswegen haben wir sind so gemacht dass
meine eltern wirklich hier bei uns mit
wohnen und vor allen dingen haben meine
eltern wirklich ihr ganzes leben lang
ganz hart gearbeitet und wirklich alles
getan für uns kinder und ich wäre heute
glaube ich nicht an der stelle wenn
meine eltern nicht gewesen wären ja
meine eltern haben mich einfach schon
immer in allem unterstützt und sie haben
wirklich alles für ihre kinder getan und
ich glaube wir als kinder sollten auch
was an die eltern zurückgeben und die
wohnen momentan noch in ihrer wohnung
die sie damals gekauft haben da bin ich
auch aufgewachsen und ich zeige euch
heute jetzt einfach mal die wohnung
meiner eltern wo sie jetzt gerade noch
leben und die wohnung die wird gebaut
haben einfach so die unterschiede und
wir gehen jetzt einfach von raum zu raum
kommt mal mit ursprünglich war geplant
dass meine eltern ich hier ins
erdgeschoss kommen damit sie einfach
keine treppen mehr steigen müssen
aber das hat einfach logistisch gesehen
nicht geklappt denn unten haben wir die
küche in der wir filmen wir haben die
büros wo alle arbeiten und deswegen war
einfach kein platz also haben wir gesagt
oben wäre ein schöner platz für die
wohnung und damit meine eltern eben
keine treppen steigen müssen haben wir
einfach einen fahrstuhl eingebaut
momentan ist es bei meinen eltern immer
so meine mama ist immer zu hause wenn
der papa nach hause kommt denn er hat
das problem dem rat auch effekt ist
immer seinen haustürschlüssel dh die
mama wartet einfach zu hause wenn der
papa kommt dann klingelte einfach
ich habe mir schon die erste lösung zum
problem denn wir haben ja im ganzen haus
unser luxus smart home system und hier
einfach dieses touchpad was man zum
einen mit einem schlüsselanhänger
bedienen kann oder mit so einem kleinen
aufkleber auf dem handy oder eben ganz
einfach mit dem kot das heißt mein papa
hat ihr den code kann nicht vergessen
und kann jederzeit ins haus rein
auch wenn er nichts dabei hat hier sind
wir jetzt gerade in der alten wohnung
meiner eltern und zwar ist es in einem
mehrfamilienhaus und hier bin ich groß
geworden ich liebe es hier hat man
nämlich einen vorteil hatten ein
fahrstuhl aber einen großen nachteil bis
zum fahrstuhl sind nämlich schon acht
stufen dh im rollstuhl hat oder nicht
richtig gehen kann oder eben einkäufe
hochschleppen muss dann muss man halt
schon die acht dritten stufen hoch dann
zum fahrstuhl und dann kann man erst
hoch in die wohnung fahren und hier
haben wir einfach alles ebenerdig also
mal kommt hier von der einfach direkt
ins haus ohne eine einzige stufe alles
komplett glatt gebaut also rollstuhl
rollator alles kein problem
normalerweise war geplant dass meine
eltern im erdgeschoss ihre wohnung haben
damit sie einfach keine treppen mehr
steigen müssen das ging einfach
logistisch gesehen nicht denn wir haben
vorne unsere küche wir haben die büros
für die mitarbeiter also das ganze team
ist unten
deswegen hat es nicht geklappt aber ich
habe sagt zumindest müssen wir dann ein
fahrstuhl einbauen damit meine eltern
einfach auch die gelegenheit haben nach
oben zu fahren jetzt können sie zwar
noch gut laufen aber keine einkauft oder
was großes hat muss man nichts schweres
schleppen und man muss vor allem auch
immer in die zukunft denken
jetzt sind sie gerade noch fit aber mein
papa da es schon 73 man weiß nie was in
ein paar jahren ist und so hat man
einfach den vorteil dass ihr denn auch
zu betätigen können fahren können
willkommen im eingangsbereich meiner
eltern ja ich habe einfach alles
großzügig geschnitten und schrank dafür
die garderobe und hier stand direkter
eingang in die wohnung
sie haben jetzt die eingangstür meiner
eltern und auch hier haben wir das ganze
hier mit diesem touchpanel gelöst denn
hier im treppenhaus haben wir unten
praktisch den eingang in die büros und
hier oben dann den eingang in die eltern
wohnung also kommt da auch nur meine
eltern rein und natürlich ihre gäste und
wir haben hier komplett im ganzen
obergeschoss diesen kers passiert auf
dem boden der meinen eltern auch richtig
gut gefällt mir auch weil er einfach
schön warm aussieht und man läuft da
gerne auch barfuß drauf auch wenn ich
gerne meine hausschuhe trage aber hier
laufe ich wirklich gerne barfuß was ihr
gleich auffällt ist dass die
eingangstüren und alle zimmertüren
wirklich breiter sind als sonst also da
mal wirklich schon noch das
altersgerechte bauen geachtet damit man
eben auch mit einem rollator reinkommt
oder mit einem rollstuhl und so hat man
einfach eine größere fläche und kommt
wirklich bequemer durch
wenn man über hindernisse im alltag
spricht denkt man glaube ich sofort
zuerst einmal ans badezimmer das
badezimmer meine eltern momentan noch
und ich finde von der größe erreicht auf
jeden fall aus macht hier eine badewanne
das waschbecken und die toilette dies in
einem extra raum was ich auch immer
ziemlich gut finde und mein papa nicht
wir haben damals ihr diese mauer
reingezogen damit war einfach noch platz
für die waschmaschine und ein trockner
haben aber jetzt ist zwar das badezimmer
echt noch gut aber wenn man sich jetzt
vorstellen im alltag da würde man nicht
mal in die badewanne steigen zum duschen
denn das ist wirklich jeden tag so ein
hindernis dann ist einfach echt ziemlich
blöd man hat nicht ebenerdiges und im
jugendalter geht es noch aber später ist
echt schwierig wir hatten eine nachbarin
die hat wirklich die ist erst mit 92
gestorben und die hat die letzten zehn
jahre ist sie nicht mehr in die
badewanne rein gegangen weil es einfach
angst hatte dass er eben hinfällt und
nicht mehr rauskommt und deswegen finde
ich eine badewanne zweimal gut aber wenn
man eine ebenerdige dusche hat ist noch
besser
haben wir hier im neuen haus jetzt ein
großzügiges bad gebaut was aber nicht so
groß ist denn man muss ja auch wenn man
seine sachen pflegen und auch putzen
können die man hat ja jetzt praktisch
und badezimmer für meine eltern dass
gäste badezimmer also dieses gäste wc
ist separat daher wussten nur die beiden
hier diesem raum wenn mir badewanne hier
das waschbecken mit toilette und gerade
bei der toilette ich glaube es gehört
wirklich auch zum altersgerechten boden
mit dazu haben wir die funktion hier mit
dem dusch wc und alle unsere duravit
toiletten haben alle ein dusch wc aber
das möchte euch dann muss separat
erklären also da warten wir einfach auf
murats erklärung und zwar ist es auch
bei meinen eltern so gehört es einfach
dazu
man wäscht sich mit sauberem wasser ab
keine feuchttücher keine
umweltverschmutzung daher ist und durch
schwitzen echt immer optimal
wir haben hier einfach ein sichtschutz
angebracht da haben wir auch dann diese
pcs angebracht die man eben auch auf
machen kann oder eben schließen kann um
sichtschutz zu haben
der mann einfach beim meister bestellt
auf marx direkt angebracht und fertig
und ja mercedes ebenerdig reinlaufen
können
leider hat es hier jetzt von pflanzen
nicht gereicht dass wir praktisch eine
dusche ohne glas gemacht haben und
karamell eltern hat mich echt ziemlich
geärgert denn da kam die idee einfach
zum schluss aber wir haben ja eine
enthärtungsanlage also eine wc anlage wo
praktisches wasser gefiltert wird so
dass einfach kalkflecken gar nicht
entsteht bzw
sie müssen echt viel viel weniger putzen
als vorher und hier können sie einfach
ganz flach hallen laufen wir stellen
hier noch einen hocker mit rein dass er
sich auch beim duschen einfach mal
hinsetzen können und später wenn man es
mal braucht kann man auch so ein
klapphocker direkt an die wand machen
und hat halt in trockau und der dusche
und badewanne meine eltern und dies auch
etwas tiefer gelegt das heißt wir haben
die wirklich in den boden eingesetzt
damit der einstieg eben nicht so hoch
ist aber man hat ja auch echt die
möglichkeit später gerade eben
fortgeschritteneren alter auf seine
badewanne einstiegshilfe mit anzubringen
und hier habe ich einfach noch die bade
war dann auflagen einfach mit gestellt
die sind auch von david und da kann sich
mein papa oder mama
können sich darauf setzen die socken
anziehen gerade bei der rituellen
waschungen mein papa muss ich ja da
immer die füße waschen und wenn er mal
oder können sich dahin setzen und
einfach ansehen und die badewanne hat
auch eine world funktion so dass sich
die beiden richtig schön entspannen
können und außerdem raten von mehreren
teller auf gering und das können sie
dann auch hier drücken und nicht immer
nur bei uns zu hause und hier stehen
wird gerade im hauswirtschaftsraum
meiner mama mein papa nutzt den vor mit
aber ich glaube die mama verbringt hier
so die meiste zeit wir hatten hier
einfach beim bau und beim einrichten
diesen langen raum übrig daneben haben
wir noch so ein technikraum oder ganze
haustechnik ist und ich habe mir gedacht
das passt hier echt ganz gut bei uns
drüben ist es das so wir haben einen
hauswirtschaftsraum unten und oben unten
sind unsere lebensmittel vorräte also
dort wo eben auch die küche ist und oben
da wo die wäsche anfällt habe ich
natürlich auch meine waschmaschine
meiner mama wohnt er jetzt hier mit
meinem papa auf einer ebene
daher sind jetzt hier vorräte und der
hauswirtschaftsraum unterwäsche raum
einfach vereint und ich haben wir
einfach regale führt zum beispiel
getränkekisten die sind bereits
angeschrägt hinten mit seiner leiste
dran damit die kiste eben nicht nach
hinten fällt und eben ganz viel stauraum
für vorräte für ihre puts sachen so dass
sie da einfach wirklich supergut
drankommt die andere seite haben wir
jetzt komplett die band mit dieser
organisations band verkleidet und zwar
finde es elemente die kann man auch bei
der küche benutzen als küchen
hintergrund und kann einfach in sachen
hier individuell verschieden und da
reinstecken wo man es drauf das haken
für handtücher für geschäfte für
handtücher für wäsche zum beispiel
hierfür die küchenrolle wobei ich hier
keinen sinn macht weil er sich an stoßen
würde also punkte zu hierhin oder gar
nicht hier hin
so stehen den hintergrund da wo sie es
eben darauf zu nutzen und so kann man
das system einfach immer wieder
individualisieren und schauen wo man es
braucht muss nicht bohren man hat keine
löcher und kann wirklich alles
individuell anpassen und die haben wir
einfach den wäsche einwurf schacht hier
kann man die wäsche einfach sortieren
der papa auch wenn sie will kann sich
jetzt im prinzip noch sticker dran
machen damit sie weiß weiße wäsche bunte
wäsche und damit aber eben auch weiß und
dann nimmt sie einfach fehl die
wäschekörbe mit der wäsche raus und kann
dann hier oben waschen und dann hast du
einfach das problem du musst die nasse
schwere wäsche von unten nach oben
befördern
und es ist einfach ziemlich anstrengend
also kriegt meine mama die waschmaschine
noch getauscht das machen bestimmte boni
und demokrat und kann dann die nasse
wäsche von oben nehmen und direkt
darunter schmeißen in den trockner mit
den federn schwerkraft und die
waschmaschine wenn sie oben ist hat man
natürlich den nachteil dass man es nicht
gut befüllen kann gerade mit dem
waschmittel arbeit haben wir auch die
lösung und zwar hat sich hier einfach
dass eidos system das heißt sie kann
hier einmal das waschmittel auffüllen
1,3 liter und die man benutzt auch kein
weichspüler das heißt auch den
weichspüler schacht kann sie benutzen
und einen halben liter waschmittel oder
ein film und hat dann fast zwei liter
waschmitteln drin und die waschmaschine
dosiert von ganz alleine das waschmittel
anhand der verschmutzung hat das calypso
natürlich auch das wasser wo so
schwartze viel zeit viel arbeit und
natürlich auch hier sind wir jetzt
gerade irgendwo meine eltern und der
papa der hat glaube ich hier in der
umgebung bei uns in der familie und im
freundeskreis die meisten schlafzimmer
schränke und betten aufgebaut der sich
nämlich auch eine schlafzimmer von nolte
daher früher gearbeitet und germersheim
und er hat es immer alles selbst
aufgebaut für alle die sich möbel
gekauft haben aber mein papa zuständig
und er hat schon ganz früh immer gesagt
wenn ihr euch ein schlafzimmer holt dann
muss es ein gutes sein und wirklich für
immer halten deswegen wir uns da
wirklich an die worte von papa geholfen
[Musik]
die möbel haben wir gemeinsam mit meinen
eltern in karlsruhe beim xxx lutz
ausgesucht haben sie dann liefern und
vom serviceteam aufbauen lassen
[Musik]
hier sind wir jetzt gerade im neuen
schlafzimmer meiner eltern und im alten
schlafzimmer war es so dass meine eltern
ein schlafzimmer von nolte hatten und
mein papa war es auch wirklich ganz
wichtig dass er wieder eine nolte
kleiderschrank bekommt und ich habe
gesagt das machen wir auf jeden fall
das haben wir einfach vor ort
konfigurieren lassen aber ich hab sagt
papa beim bett da nehme jetzt einfach in
burg springt und da haben wir wirklich
einfach vom xxx los in der burg springt
abteilung bei world of box springt die
betten getestet und meine eltern haben
mich hier so ein feature mit drin und
zwar ist es so wenn meine mama erkältet
ist dann kriegt sie immer nicht so gut
läuft und bei erst einfach mit den
bronchien glaube ich dass er einfach ein
bisschen erhöht liegen muss und hier
machen wir das jetzt einfach so sie legt
sich ins bett und das ist alltag und
verletzten verletzungs gerecht
von mira ist gerade verletzt aber nicht
alt da haben sie hier ihre fernbedienung
auf beiden seiten
und dann kann sie einfach die füße
hochlegen oder hier oben das hier
erhöhen so verlegt die oma hatte kopf
hoch und über die physiologie oder wir
zwei schlafen jetzt einfach hier
dann machst du mal ein nickerchen samira
und ich zeige euch mal den
kleiderschrank den wir konfiguriert
haben
die prinzessin auf der erbse und die
haben wir jetzt den kleiderschrank vom
nolte darlegt mein papa ich viel wert
drauf vor allem haben wir auch hier
darauf geachtet einfach regionaler
hersteller zu verwenden und zu
unterstützen auch sagt mein papa früher
schon immer gesagt daher sollte beim
bett dieter knoll und haben einfach
großzügig geplant dass mein papa hat es
hier genügend platz für seine hemden
meine mama für ihre kleider und gerade
weil sie da oben schlecht dran kommen
haben wir hier auf der seite einen
kleider lift und zwar können jetzt mein
papa und mama hier die hemden reinhängt
und wirklich einfach hier die
kleiderstange herunterziehen
und gerade wenn dann die wäsche gemacht
wird und alles aufgegangen wird kann
meine mama ist ja schön aufhängen oder
eben auch im täglichen gebrauch einfach
hier herunter ziehen
für mich haben wir das nicht gebraucht
wenn man auch den gleichen
kleiderschrank trüben
ich komme so ganz gut dran aber der mut
habt auch in kleider lift und hier ist
er meiner meinung nach fast zwei
schönsten raum hier drin nach der küche
und zwar ist es das gästezimmer meine
eltern meine mama hat vier geschwister
und die kommen sie auch alle regelmäßig
besuchen meine tanten und auch meine
schwester kommt ab und zu hier wohnt in
aachen und dann ist hier einfach ein
wunderschöner raum den meine mama hier
gestaltet hat und vor allem richtig drin
richtig gut nach holz weil alle möbel
hieraus richtig massivem holz sind und
ich finde es ist einfach ein schöner
warmer raum geworden
richtig schön herzlich und einladend und
vor allem hat er meine mama das große
hobby nähen und sie ändert auch immer
ganz viel also für uns kinder und für
die enkelkinder und hier hat sich eben
auch so ein bisschen irre sachen
verstaut kann die dann bei bedarf
rausholen und hat einfach ein schönes
aufgeräumter sauberes zimmer
ist jetzt kein mega spektakulärer raum
aber ich wollte euch natürlich auch hier
das gäste-wc zeigen dann einfach ein
dusch wc und ein waschbecken für die
gäste und auch schon großzügig und
großflächig auch man kann hier auch
wirklich mit einem rollator oder
rollstuhl reinfahren und hier haben wir
was richtig schöne an der wand und zwar
habe ich hier so kleine tabletts dran
gemacht mit fäden also mit seilen dran
und habe hier die pflanzen drin und
meine mama die marke pflanzen also die
legt blumen über alle sondern hier
einfach schon mal ihre pflanzen
eingesetzt damit sie anfangen zu wachsen
und das sieht hier echt schön aus aber
ich finde auto ist ein richtig schönes
gästebad geworden
im gäste wc meine eltern haben in der
ganzen wohnung auch das luxus und smart
home system das heißt egal welchen raum
zu betreten
das licht geht automatisch an und auch
automatisch wieder aus und in manchen
räumen wie zum beispiel im
hauswirtschaftsraum gibt es auch gar
keinen lichtschalter weil man ihnen da
einfach nicht braucht das nicht schaltet
sich nur dann an wenn die helligkeit von
draußen nicht mehr ausreicht das heißt
ab der abenddämmerung und in den räumen
haben wir überall auf lautsprecher an
der decke und man kann im prinzip
einstellen in welchem raum an musik
haben möchte wenn man im raum ist ich
stehe gerade eben gästebad und hier ist
es so dass er den raum betritt dann
kommt hier die musik so kann man zum
beispiel unangenehme geräusche einfach
ein bisschen übertönen
hier ist der lieblingsplatz von meinem
papa und von der l
mein papa legt nämlich gerne mal die
füße hoch hat er sicher auch verdient
und hier sehen wir gerade im wohnzimmer
und die wohnung die ist etwa ich glaube
110 quadratmeter groß und wir haben ja
echt schon ganz vieles erlebt als er
morath und ich haben uns sehr kennen
gelernt und habe hier die eltern
vorgestellt
dann haben wir uns das album gefeiert
mit fast 90 leuten war auch eine große
menge und die kinder sind hier
aufgewachsen ich bin hier aufgewachsen
echt schön und mein papa der sitzt immer
hier will abends dann fernsehschauen und
seine serien anschauen wenn die füße
hochlegen und meine eltern sind echt so
die haben sie noch nie einen luxus
gegönnt dem sie noch nie neue möbel
gekauft sondern immer wirklich gute
hochwertige möbel meisten gebraucht von
freunden zum beispiel oder dem tief von
uns genommen oder von meiner schwester
und das hat mir gesagt dass er mit
und dies das hier ist der lieblingsplatz
von papa und da direkt am wohnzimmer
dran ist noch der balkon hier in dieser
küche habe ich meine leidenschaft fürs
kochen und backen entdeckt das war so
die erste küche in der ich gekocht habe
gebacken habe meine ersten torten für
geburtstage hochzeiten das war hier drin
von der größe her finde ich perfekt
braucht man eigentlich nicht größer was
ich nur schade findet jetzt vor allem
jetzt wenn man diese offenen küchen
kennt es ist halt in der geschlossenen
küche des tiers die küche
draußen ist es erst zimmer unternehmen
ist das wohnzimmer und meine mama die
steht halt wirklich dann den ganzen tag
hier drin und kocht ist auch irgendwie
getrennt von einem paparazzo der stadt
im wohnzimmer sie ist dann hier und zu
zweit hier kochen ist sehr schwierig und
wenn ihr euch erinnert meine zweite
küche in der ich auch die videos gedreht
habe die war genau so groß da hatte ich
auch die tür im hintergrund das fenster
im rücken oder andersrum da war immer
die kamera
und die war genau so groß und ich habe
dann einfach so eine zeit voll was ich
immer hier in die mitte gestellt habe
und da meine videos gedreht hat und dann
sind wir umgezogen in die große küche
damit ich bessere videos machen kann und
ich habe ich im prinzip die erste hälfte
meines lebens verbracht also zumindest
bis ich 19 war doch nicht ganz die
hälfte zwei drittel
und dann bin ich nur mora
zusammengezogen ja das ist die küche nur
schade eben dass sie geschlossen ist und
deswegen bekommt die mama jetzt eine
schöne offene küche und ein zimmer
völlig egal wie groß oder klein dick
hier ist am ende ist wirklich immer so
zumindest bei uns alle versammeln sich
in der küche und das ist bei uns bei der
mama hier genauso ihr seht den kleinen
tisch und trotzdem passen da dann alle
dran die ganze familie auch wenn man ein
bisschen sich fitschen muss aber immer
schön am gemütlichsten immer hier in der
kirche und haben wir jetzt den wohn
essbereich mit küche in der alten
wohnung was so dass die küche getrennt
war das esszimmer getrennt und das
wohnzimmer um meine mama war einfach
immer den ganzen tag in der küche und
hat für uns gekocht und jetzt hat sie im
prinzip alles zu sammeln und dann sind
mama und papa den ganzen tag mit uns
vereint hinter mir seht ihr jetzt
einfach das wohnzimmer mit dem schönen
sofa und zwar das sofa die funktionen
dass meine eltern einfach die knöpfe
drücken können und dann fährt er fußteil
hoch oder eben auch den nacken
und das ist echt super bequem denn mein
papa hatte in der alten wohnung nämlich
einen sessel das war so ein
fernsehsessel und sein entspannungs
sessel wo er immer den hocker athen
geben müssen und das fällt jetzt weg
hier steht kein hocker herum und er kann
es einfach hoch oder wieder runter
fahren was mit eltern hier auch haben
ist eine zentrale staubsauger anlage
hier einfach das rohr anschließen und
sie muss den staubsauger hier nicht mehr
in der wohnung herum tragen sondern hat
einfach an ein paar stellen diesen
anschluss macht den sauger dran also das
saubere und fertig dann hört man auch
nicht so viel und der papa wird nicht
gestört und januar dann direkt den
essbereich
da macht die samira meister mit der oma
hausaufgaben oder für spiel und die
haben wir jetzt die landhausküche die
farben haben wir bei der front eine frau
gewählt und die strafe arbeitsplatte in
diesem schönen marmor und die küche
gefällt mir richtig gut vor allem ist
euch gleich der boden aufgefallen da
haben wir die wehr platten mit diesem
grau blau grünen muster und passt hier
echt perfekt rein aber ich glaube die
küche ist und großes thema das würde ich
einfach in einem separaten video machen
und euch hier alle funktionen zeigen und
die geräte wenn ihr möchtet schreibt
einfach gerne in die kommentare
hier sehen wir jetzt gerade auf dem
balkon meine eltern und mein papa hat
eine satellitenschüssel installiert
damit er eben auch türkisches fernsehen
empfangen kann nimmt aber so viel platz
weg dass man hier eigentlich nicht
sitzen kann aber meine mama pflegt hier
ihre pflanzen und züchtet auch hier
pflanzen die dann später heraus in einem
schrebergarten gehen und hier hat man
den perfekten blick nach unten denn wir
haben hier immer auf dem spielplatz
gespielt und meine mama kommt einfach
aus dem wohnzimmer heraus vom balkon
herunter immer schauen was wir gerade
machen und ich habe ich meine kindheit
verbracht unser spielplatz gut die
spielgeräte haben sich ein bisschen
geändert aber es gibt ihn nicht groß
geworden und meine eltern haben
natürlich auch ihren eigenen balkon wenn
sie mal keine zeit mit uns verbringen
wollen und einfach mal alleine die zeit
genießen wollen hier muss hier
allerdings dazu sagen das geländer ist
bestellt das kommt erst noch da kommt
noch so ein alu geländer hin
und die haben wir auch einfach ein
fliegengitter hin gemachten
insektengitter beim rolle meister
bestellt und haben hier das auch einfach
auf maß gemacht
so kommt man raus ich bin vielleicht
gemütlich er ist schon alles gepflanzt
und wer jetzt meine eltern demnächst ein
ziehen in den nächsten paar tagen dann
ist alles einfach schon schön
ja wir haben wir so eine kleine
sitzgruppe hose gemütlich sitzen können
und gerade weil der balkon in der alten
wohnung zu klein war ich meinem papa der
satellitenschüssel hin gebaut damit der
türkisches fernsehen hat und da war der
halbe balkon schon zugestellt und man
konnte sich vielleicht mal hinsetzen
aber nicht wirklich mit der familie
draußen sitzen
wir mussten praktisch egal ob winter
oder sommer immer drinnen sitzen und
essen
und jetzt haben sich hier wirklich ganz
viel platz ich habe eine sitzgruppe wo
sie abends gemütlich sitzen können mit
ihren enkeln und kindern frühstücken
können und es ist wirklich einfach echt
schön meine eltern können jetzt viel
mehr zeit draußen an der frischen luft
verbringen und hier immer noch eine
richtig schöne sitzgruppe und da können
meine eltern dann in ruhe frühstücken
oder zu abend essen und da haben wir es
einfach so gemacht ich bin in die
gartenabteilung beim los und habe mir
einfach verschiedene sets angeschaut der
stube hat mir super gefallen weil er aus
teakholz ist um wirklich ewig lebt wenn
man ihn richtig pflegt teakholz hat er
gerade den vorteil dass es wirklich
draußen bei nässe bei hitze wirklich
perfekt hält und da hat mir der tierisch
gut gefalle mit der sitzbank und die
drei stühle und wenn es einfach dort vor
ort mit den mitarbeitern kombiniert also
ich hab da guck mal die stühle hätte ich
gerne und den tisch und die zwei stunden
noch mit dabei und wenn es einfach
ausprobiert und das ist der vorteil den
man hat wenn man wirklich vor ort in
einem möbelgeschäft nach möbeln schaut
das kannst du online hat nicht machen
also da kann man sich zwar anschauen und
bisschen vorstellen aber vor ort kann
man es ausprobieren um mal drauf sitzen
ja und vor allem hat man die beratung
hätte ich vorher gewusst dass man immer
was ich so viele pflanzen aus für die
terrasse
dann hätten wir wahrscheinlich mit dem
bewässerungssystem gearbeitet damit
einfach nichts mehr gießen muss jetzt
haben wir so aber wir haben einfach
jetzt im nachhinein hier draußen da
hatten wir schon anschluss für wasser da
haben wir echt gut mitgedacht beim bau
empfehle ich auch jedem der eine
außenanlage hat immer direkt den
anschluss für wasser anbringen und jetzt
haben wir hier einfach noch einen
gartenschlauch her
das heißt meine mama kann hier oder
meint opfer kann ihr blumen gießen ohne
sich bücken zu müssen und kann hier
einfach gießen
und alles ist perfekt den schlauch
wieder aufräumen machen keine unordnung
auf der terrasse und sie dort nicht
sauber und aufgeräumt vor allem kann man
hier auch mal die terrasse abspritzen
wenn sie schmutzig ist und man muss
keine schwere gießkannen tragen die
meisten sagen ja dass gerade ein
smartphone system für ältere nicht
geeignet ist aber ich kann euch vom
gegenteil überzeugen denn gerade für
ältere ist es wirklich super geeignet
smart features wie zum beispiel gerade
wenn man schwer hört oder wirklich auch
bei gehörlosen menschen kann man das so
schalten dass wenn jemand an der
haustüre klingelt das eben klinge
geräusch kommt oder man kommt einfach
mit dem licht und dann blinkt das licht
und er weiß noch wo es hat gerade jemand
an der haustür geklingelt ich höre es
nicht aber ich sehe auf jeden fall ist
klingeln und so dinge sind zum beispiel
auch dass wir meine eltern in urlaub
fahren dann machen sie einfach vorne am
hauseingang drücken sie dreimal auf den
schalter und dann ist einfach der
urlaubs modus aktiviert das haus weiß
die eltern sie netzwerk die alarmanlage
ist scharf schalten und vor allem fahren
auch die rollos immer hoch und runter
das haus belüftet sich die energie fährt
runter das heißt es heißt nicht unnötig
und wären wirklich wenige lichtschalter
im haus und wenn dann hat man wirklich
nur einen und nicht ganz viele
obwohl man viele lichter im haus hat und
zwar würde so programmiert dass
praktisch in der mitte das licht an und
aus geht oder man die lichtstimmung
ändert rechts machen wir musik an oder
musik aus und die jalousie hoch und
runter aber man muss es wirklich gar
nicht bedienen weil man ja alles schon
vorprogrammiert hat das heißt alles
funktioniert von alleine aber wenn man
es mal nur noch ändern möchte kann man
das tun
ich habe aber auch schon wieder über
unsere smartphone-system gemacht hat
könnt ihr gerne mal reinschauen
falls ihr nähere infos braucht und was
wir hier bei meinen eltern gemacht haben
und es ist wirklich super praktisch es
gibt so eine art notruf schalter und es
ist wirklich bei jedem schalter den wir
im haus hier haben ist so wenn man
länger als drei sekunden mit der hand
drauf drückt dann wird der notruf
aktiviert und bei uns ist es so dass
dann einen notruf also einen anruf vom
von der wohnung meiner eltern einfach an
unser telefon kommt und ich weiß okay
ebenfalls stimmen jetzt mit mama oder
papa nicht und man kann es auch so
machen dass wenn man wirklich alleine
wohnt macht vielleicht keine familie
oder freunde das man dann direkt das
ganze an den notruf schaltet also an die
feuerwehr zum beispiel oder ein
seniorenheim oder an die tagespflege und
das finden
ist schon ein richtig gutes dem weg ein
richtig gutes feature was wirklich auch
leben retten kann
ich glaube ich habe jetzt genug gezeigt
von der wohnung meiner eltern hat hier
nach zwei zusammen bis zum nächsten mal
und bis zum nächsten update
die mieter meines papas sind damals
ausgezogen
es war echt ganz spontan und kurzfristig
[Applaus]
noch eine runde ja noch eine pirouette
der ic von karlsruhe nach mannheim
das bistro das bordrestaurants leider
kaputt
wir haben nur noch drei flaschen wasser
an bord weil wir nicht egal ich mache
jetzt einfach ein service mitarbeiter
werde ihn in die drei flaschen wasser
austeilen
vielen dank für ihr verständnis trotzdem
kostet ab 200 euro
meine eltern haben mich einfach schon im
studium wie man schon unterstützt sie
haben immer nach samira geschaut wenn
ich weg war und sie sind einfach immer
da und halten immer zu mir sind noch
immer
das ist schon gut kurz vor feierabend
der lkw-fahrer hier draußen zu drehen
und damit meine eltern eben keine
treppen steigen müssen haben wir einfach
einen fahrstuhl eingebaut und auch hier
haben sie einfach war einfach